Omarosa spit today you and I are gonna
play some of the oculus
every once in a while I find a game that
is just so beautiful and so breathtaking
then I just feel like
but the VR experience you know what
let's not waste any more time let's get
it did it I may not return that's the
same man I once was
oh my god I told it hey buddy hey ow
nice ass great functionality and volume
men design oh god what is that he
doesn't have an S he's an SS man this is
so [ __ ] weird yeah god it's beautiful
oh dude dude that guy's face why is it
no don't come on guys what's this [ __ ]
literally and get stop I'm scared get oh
I'm really scared I've seen it all
it's okay cool
I wish it's a heart oh my god
now kiss mad kiss come on yes yes
[Music]
yes the moon is great duh this game ever
Cana nighttime terror oh my god what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] I'm playing is this
little guy hahahaha this is so [ __ ]
weird why do I feel like such a pervert
looking at them put the [ __ ] hey it
feels so real he's like my little friend
when do I get my tactical nuke I don't I
don't know what else to say but that's a
that's a brilliant idea
I love that I'm scared but I must be a
sperm that's what I'm doing okay let's
do it
oh god that noise oh god I'm in a vagina
this is the greatest moment of my laughs
I mean not really what a Warner Bros
I've done this one time before I don't
remember but they are my friends I can't
kill them they're just kidding oh my god
this is so [ __ ] confusing I'm
swimming around in a vagina I'm swimming
around in a god so this is how babies
are born
now I know what to answer to my nephew
whoever came up with this game idea
brilliant just brilliant good job your
mother is proud of you yeah
[Music]
this game was sent over by my friends
over at GTA hey if oh cool oh my God my
legs it's like a pity pie simulator oh
my god let's start with horror no I'm
sorry I changed my mind please can I
have another game we are dead
low power please activate generators god
damnit alright [ __ ] we are so dead bros
alright the generators
what my room was so nice and cozy what
happened oh [ __ ] yeah here it is
that's the generator hater don't don't
taste my nipples bros don't taste my
nips
ah [ __ ] stop why did you run like that
it's dangerous to run in corridors
doesn't she know all right here's a
generator all right we got 2 out of 4
and I disable them oh my god that's
awesome oh god it's so dark I don't like
this last generator I'm going he meant
Kinesis whoa what that's awesome
hi this is really cool oh my god
I shoot balls it's like a space yo-yo
[Music]
what stop it stop it Pierce you idiot
she throwing barrels at me [ __ ]
oh I caught it baby fibroids the g28
taste my ass senpai ha ha ha oh my god
dude
is that y'all you got some fight no what
is he doing it's not worth it
no the activate yes I did enjoy it oh I
love that oh god what is happening
Oh God Santa I'm terrified and turned on
at the same time don't hurt me it's not
Christmas nice tits
I've seen it all nothing nothing
confuses me anymore all right brothers I
hope you had fun playing with me today I
had a lot of fun playing see on my
[ __ ] board all right thanks for
hanging out with me today bros as always
stay awesome the series where we try and
find the scariest game ever as if
watching a man with big headphones and
pink sweater it's not scary enough we're
gonna start off with safety blanket I
don't know if this game is actually
scary